It's taken a few years, but we've finally
gotten some clarification on perhaps the most
messed-up moment in the ​Star Wars​ prequel
trilogy.
The moment in question comes in Episode II:
Attack of the Clones when it appears that
young Boba Fett is grieving over the death
of his father, Jango while seemingly holding
his severed head.
Actor Daniel Logan, who portrayed Boba in
the film, recently took to Twitter to state
that this was not exactly as it seemed.
You may remember that near the film's end,
Anakin and Padme are captured by Jango as
they're attempting to reach Obi-Wan Kenobi.
Luckily, a group of Jedi arrive to rescue
them, including Yoda and Mace Windu, who takes
on Jango.
The Master Jedi proves to be too formidable
for the bounty hunter, who is quickly decapitated
by Windu.
As the fighting continues, a brief shot shows
young Boba apparently picking up the helmet
containing his father's severed head, looking
appropriately traumatized.
The beheading and Boba's reaction stands as
one of the most disturbing happenings in Star
Wars history; sure, Jango is a ruthless mercenary
and Boba is a clone, but the sight of a kid
clutching his parental figure's decapitated
head seems just a little bit intense for the
series.
However, according to Logan, when Boba picks
up that helmet, dear old dad's head is not
actually in it.
"You can see the shadow of Jango's head falling
out just after Mace 'removes' it from his
body and the helmet goes flying.
So, no, no head in it when #BobaFett picks
up the helmet.
Thanks @SamuelLJackson!"
We're not sure why Logan would deign to offer
thanks to the dude who lightsabered his dad's
head off.
At any rate, it's telling that despite the
answer to the question being right there in
the film, the shadowy image of Jango's falling
head slipped by so many fans that Logan had
to set the record straight.
Perhaps, even in shadow, the image was just
too gruesome for director George Lucas to
linger on for too terribly long.
"Unlikely but seems to be true!"
Of course, it's not like the Star Wars movies
don't have their share of dark moments; even
the original trilogy hit us with scenes like
the aftermath of the stormtrooper raid on
the home of Luke's aunt and uncle in Episode
IV: A New Hope.
If that's not enough for you, there's always
Darth Vader performing an impromptu amputation
of Luke's hand in Episode V: The Empire Strikes
Back.
For the really bloodthirsty, there's also
Luke's merciless torture at the hands of Palpatine
while screaming for his help at the conclusion
of Episode VI: Return of the Jedi.
Still, don't forget that Disney has stewardship
of the entire Star Wars series, having purchased
Lucasfilm in 2012.
A bloodless onscreen decapitation is one thing;
a small child holding his father's head is
quite another.
What we're saying is that if it weren't made
clear within the film that the helmet was
empty when Boba picks it up, Disney may have
had to go back to do a little Lucas-style
revision to make it so.
Of course, when you think about it, this raises
another question: for the remainder of the
battle, where exactly was Jango's head?
Was it just kind of sitting there on the ground,
and if so, was it somewhere that young Boba
could see it?
Upon further reflection, we're thinking that
Jango's head probably was hanging around for
the rest of the battle, which means that Logan's
explanation actually serves to make the tragic
scene even worse.
Well, nobody ever said that being the cloned
son of a Mandalorian mercenary in a galaxy
far, far away was easy.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.